Cara special is one of the most
influential people in the tech World
here in the United States she has been
working for the Washington Post for the
New York Times for the Wall Street
Journal and is hosting some
award-winning podcasts her latest
podcast is called on with Kara Swisher
Kara thank you so much for being on with
deutschevela today Kara let's talk
Twitter you previously stated that musk
could be the one to solve some of the
Twitter problems why did he seem like
the right fit at the time for you he had
the money he was very wealthy he's got
the means he certainly has a lot of
support in Silicon Valley and in Tech
he's famous you know it sometimes takes
a really well-known person to to do
these kind of things and he has
technical skills I mean he already has
people who have the technical skills and
so and lastly he was a very Avid user of
the of the of the of the service and so
you know that's the kind of person you
want to be maybe bringing it to its full
potential and so you know he certainly
could have done it quietly taking it
private would have been was a good idea
getting rid of people was a good idea
it's just how he's doing it is the
problem now and uh it may have the same
outcome but it certainly tarnished his
brand rather significantly you know him
fairly well Kara so what what exactly
did musk go wrong today he tweeted a
picture of guns like why
um he tweeted a misinformation about
Paul Pelosi's attack using an anti-gay
Trope now he's attacking Apple for not
advertising on Twitter Apple which is
the who has to make a decision if the if
the service becomes unsafe to remove it
from the App Store
um of course that's what he's doing he's
front loading that fight so it looks
like it's free speech flight and not a
safety issue on Twitter which the only
way Apple would remove an app is if
there's a safety issue and so it's a
real um he's doing all kinds of things
that are incredibly divisive and angry
and in your face a lot of it is stunts
so do not take them seriously he's
trying to call attention to the platform
he's essentially committing a traffic
accident every day in order to get
people interested in him and that's not
and that's no way to run a business as
far as I could tell from the people who
have been really successful why is he
doing that Karen
um because there's you know he's always
a lot of money there's a lot of money at
stake here he's got a he may be one one
theory is that he's trying to bring down
the price of the debt uh so that he can
buy it up for cheap and then own the
whole company from the banks that lent
him 13 billion dollars and so the more
he [ __ ] talks the company the more um
the the price goes down he could buy up
that debt and own the whole company and
then later clean it up and take it
public there's lots of different ways
reasons he could do it he's he's in a
really untenable position because he
paid too much and so he's got to figure
out a way to pay less and then then fix
it and then uh bring it public
presumably well that's dangerous I mean
he he puts the whole platform in Risk
right yes of course he doesn't care I
mean this is he's overpaid for like at
the very heart of it away from all his
Antics and his you know his
baiting of people and his rude remarks
every time he's a rude remark of me I
know I'm winning because he's desperate
about something and so he's desperately
trying to figure a way not to lose as
much money as possible and maybe make
some money here and because he because
of the the original sin is he paid 44
billion dollars for a company worth
maybe eight billion dollars that's where
he's got it he's operating from and so
um I don't think he's you know you know
financially suicidal here I think he's
got to figure out a way out of having to
over not having to overpay he overpaid
and he was made to buy it because that's
what he said he was going to do and so
he's caught in a financial bind and he's
trying to find a way to get out of it
and if if
um you know saying Hey to Kanye West you
know a deeply anti-semitic person or uh
bear hugging the right is going to work
he'll do it he doesn't care how
dangerous is this Kara you just said
that he's he calls himself like a free
speech absolutely so whatever he cuts
people off all the time it's such it's
you know Enos it's crap it's okay it's
crap I what I want to ask you is like
how how dangerous it is it really that
Twitter becomes a platform for for hate
speech under his leadership well then
it's a bunch of hate speakers just
talking to each other it doesn't I don't
think it has an influence what if
everyone runs off the platform the whole
beauty of Twitter is everybody's there
talking to each other it's a very small
company let's just say like he goes on
and on about the numbers it's only
because they're there to look at the
traffic accident that he's making and
it's still so small compared to tick
tock and Facebook and uh Instagram it's
it's minuscule and now it has almost no
advertising business and so it's not a
big business and it's not it's a big
platform among the media and politicians
uh and that's it that's it sorry and
that's why I get so much attention and
that's where what's the what precisely
is the power that it has that Marjorie
we know Marjorie Charles green is an
unrepentant anti-semite and racist oh I
didn't know that before I did know that
like so she gets to say more terrible
Jewish space laser stuff okay like I
don't know what power it gives her
necessarily except for
um within the Republican Party certainly
so we wouldn't miss Twitter if Twitter
would be dead no no lots of companies
have gone come and gone and I mean he's
going to do his level best to try to get
his money back here and so that's what
he's got to do and so again he will
resort to increasing numbers of antics
and and he has two threats to him one is
the bank's foreclose if they don't if
they don't take the bait and let him buy
back is dead uh or and that's in April
and he's got to pay it back and he's got
to find get his rich friends and himself
to Fork over money as Tesla stock is
going down he's got he's rich but he's
not that rich right you know it's it's a
big chunk
um and it's sort of throwing money out
the door essentially or
um Apple and Google can throw him off
the platform if he creates an unsteady
platform they've done it before they did
it with parlor
um that could happen that could be that
would be devastating to the company and
that's why today he's attacking Apple so
whatever
so Kerry you said he it was the right
thing to get uh to lay some people off
maybe you can talk a little bit about
the mood amongst those who survived the
layoffs at Twitter right now well they
feel like hostages that's my impression
um they don't a lot of them are on Jesus
or they don't have a choice for lots of
different reasons
um I'm interviewing someone tomorrow who
he had touted as being his guy and he
left he just couldn't take it I think I
well I'm excited to talk to him about it
publicly but everyone I've talked to
that stayed there and then left in the
last we wasn't laid off is like it's
it's just capricious and it's being run
by
um uh the name they have for the people
around Elon are flying monkeys which is
like from The Wizard of Oz
um they feel like they don't know what
they're doing
um now look this company I've written
about it for years and years it's
overstaffed just like a lot of tech
companies the difference is Google can
afford it and Twitter never could
um and so it had too many people doing
too many things
um it never took advantage of
advertising it was always right there or
around they had Vine before there was
Tick Tock they had Periscope before
there were you know Facebook lives and
so they were always there but they never
were able to execute on a vision of
subscription or payments or all kinds of
stuff that they should have and it's
because it was too small and and at the
same time was run and kind of this
haphazard Way by a series of
um Chief Executives only one really did
very well which was Dick Costello but it
still was too small so if if he doesn't
if El musk won't be able to restore
Twitter what platforms do you think
could take its place so any of them all
of them I mean you know I'm working on
I'm advising one called post which is by
the guy who created ways I've never
agreed to advise someone and this is the
first time in my career I've been an
entrepreneur so I have a history of
doing that
um it's very interesting we'll see it's
very hard to create these things you
know you can still use Facebook and
Instagram and Tick Tock is killing it
um in terms of users and young people
and people excited there's obviously the
major issues with the links with the
Chinese government and that is a very
serious issue I wrote a column about
this three years ago saying I love Tick
Tock but I don't love the Chinese
government and so I'm using a burner
phone and so you have to like really
there there may not be another version
of this and maybe someone else will own
Twitter someday but it's such a hot mess
and it's been a hot mess it's whole
history and he's just making it Messier
is really what's happening okay you're a
journalist Facebook in a way is also
over as a reliable news source they
change kind of the ideology Tick Tock as
you just said is closely inclined with
uh with China now we have Twitter what
does that mean for the media strategies
of of media companies well interestingly
I interviewed uh the head of Axel
Springer this year and he said he's
trying his best to stay off Tick Tock
right it's very hard it's very hard to
resist because that's where the the
eyeballs are I think media companies
really did abrogate their uh
technological responsibility very early
on by letting these companies take over
the the the distribution means and so
it's going to be really hard to figure
out where they can get uh get people to
listen and and and you know it's not a
three in the United States there were
three broadcast networks that was it
right and you could complain about that
one time someone was saying this is
terrible all these people speaking on
the internet and I said it used to be a
dozen men white men on the Upper East
Side of New York that decided everything
that's not good either right and so
there's a there's a medium to creating
these things but I do think
um you know younger people are are
finding all kinds of different ways to
get information and I think media
companies need to be creative in doing
so obviously cable is down television is
watching us down
um and so you have to find different
ways to tell stories and bring them to
people uh I think it'll probably
coalesce around a few strong media
Brands the New York Times is a near news
Monopoly in the United States as far as
I can tell the others are trying the
Washington Post happens to be owned by
one of another one of the world's
richest men uh but still hard time and
so the question is how do you avoid
Monopoly news systems once again that we
had had before how long will that's my
last question Kara how long will Elon
Musk like be with Fred or what's your
guess I don't know I don't know I think
he's uh he seems to be enjoying himself
I guess if that's enjoyable
um it's a I call them my greatest
disappointment he was a Visionary he's a
Visionary in rockets and cars but this
is like watching a very badly raised and
behaved 11 year old you know with keys
to the Porsche and unlimited
um uh sugar treats just doing whatever
he wants and that's never ends well
okay thank you for sharing your thoughts
Cara and we talk soon again thanks have
a good one thanks